after so many time
but
the moment i arrived here
i felt very happy
and i really want to begin
the training sessions
i really wanted to be quick
i'm really enjoying my time in paris
since the first minute
my family my people
but really really my only
will now is to begin the training
sessions i want to work with the staff
and with my teammates and begin this new
moment of my life
i really want to thank the president and
leonardo and the whole club for the way
they received me
since the first day after the press
release in
barcelona
and they really were quick in the
negotiations and it's been quite easy
actually
it was a very tricky situation and they
really solved problems
it was not easy and they did it well so
really thank you for that
i repeat but i'm very happy to be here
and
i'm i have this will to play
i'm really impatient
i still want to play i still want to win
as i wanted at the first moment of my
career and with this club the staff
i think this club is really ready to
fight for all the trophies this is my
goal
i want to
keep growing
keep winning titles and
that's why i come here to this club
i hope we can
make it happen i really want to thank
paris and it's been all crazy my arrival
it was a surprise
so thank you again for the way they
received me and i'm sure i'm going to
enjoy the time with this team and we are
going to fight
for the
aim of the club i really want to begin
now and thanks again to
the president to leonardo and
thanks psg and
thank you for having me here
and i want to begin now
thank you
let's go through some questions and
answers
good evening
leonel
afp how do you feel
playing alongside messi and mbappe
it's really crazy and i'm really happy
about that
sharing
the day-to-day life with them with all
the
the squad
really there are some transfers
amazing transfers so
the team is incredible and i really want
to
train and compete now
because i'm going i'm going to be
playing with the best players it's very
nice
it's an incredible experience to be able
to enjoy
this
hi
liam
from le parisien welcome to paris
when do you think you will be able to
play your first minutes in the
french championship
actually i don't know
i was
on holidays and
it's very new so i i spoke yesterday
with i spoke yesterday with the
technical staff so maybe i need a
pre-season
myself
i'm going to begin to train and work
and i hope i can
play as soon as i can
i really want to
but i can't answer exactly to your
question
when i feel it when the staff is
thinks
i'm okay well then i'll be ready
and willing to play
good morning leo for the newspaper
l'equipe
you said you were very sad about leaving
vasa
and the joy
about arriving here in psg so today was
the strongest feeling the joy the
sadness
everything that happened to me this last
week
has been
very strange
it's been hard it's been quick it's been
emotional
i can't forget what i lived and
experienced in barcelona
but i really really feel impatient and
happy about this new life
at sport level and
with my family as well
i'm very happy
this whole week i've been
going through up and downs
but we are processing all of these
every day a little by little
every day we are processing
hi leo
al jazeera
president
we know that here it's paris and
we know that the dream of paris is
dreaming bigger every day one of the
limits of this
leo welcome
you've seen that the
people from paris have been waiting for
you for three days
some fans
were at le bourget airport for so many
times
what the message you sent
you sent to the fans in france
i think that our goal
everybody knows
our goal we want to win all the trophies
all the
games
it never changed
and now with
leo
we are close to winning but we want to
win more
i think now we need to work and to win
each game
to win the trophy
we really
we really need to have discipline and to
win every game
as i said
i'm really grateful
i'm grateful to the people in the street
i was in barcelona when the
the press
told about that and i have seen things
from there from spain and the people was
already outside and
it was incredible to see them outside in
the streets and
so i'm really grateful and i want to
thank them and i really want to see them
now
to see them in the city
in the
stadium so it will be an incredible year
and we are going to enjoy all of this
good
evening i'm edward c france television
welcome leo congratulations for this
historical transfer
there are a lot of questions about
around kilian mbappe after the arrival
of leo what about the future of kylian
mbappe then
well i think everybody knows
the future of kilian
people from paris and the players is
really a competitive player
he wants to win he wants to
win trophies
he said it
in public
he wants he wanted a competitive team
and i think we've got the most
competitive in the world so there is no
excuse for him now he can't do anything
else but staying
good evening
fa agency you've already won for
champions league what do you need what
does a team need
to win the champions league
it's not easy
sometimes you can have the best team in
the world and you don't win the
champions league
this is football
and sometimes
the margins the details
for some details you can be knockout
paris knows it perfectly
they've been so close to
a victory in champions league but
they couldn't make it but it was very
close
in this competition the best teams are
playing it's very difficult to win it
so you
you need a very united squad
a group
this dressing room for what you can see
from outside
is very united but you already you also
need
the luck
but you can also chase the luck
in champions league there is
not always the best team wins
it's a very special competition
and that's why it's so beautiful and so
important because they all want to win
we all want to win this competition
good morning leah
alpha spark plus and canada plus
what does psg represent for you and how
can you bring your experience and
presidents with leo messi in psg do you
think you are now the favorites number
one for the champions league
well i think
this team is already
done and ready
and there are some new
transfers but
they've been very close to win the
champions and they are ready
i just come here to help
i'll try to give my best with my
illusion
my goal and my dream
is to win against
again this trophy and i think that paris
is the best place
to have a chance to win it again
i think
are we favorites or not i think our team
is very good
but we never won the champions league so
we need to work
we need to win
each game
last year it was very complicated
it's not easy as leo said
it's not easy to win the temperance
league with we're focused and
we just
take one step at a time
we don't hide our
goal our objective
but first of all we will focus on the
league
the ligand and then after the 15th of
september we'll think about the
champions league
it's maybe easy to say that we are a
favorite
that's
of course our goal
but we just have to remain quiet and we
need to work
and work
hola
hi leah i'll try to ask in spanish
four years ago when neymar arrived here
it was
quite crazy and now
the club
has got another dimension
is it
one of the reason you choose
paris saint-germain because of the
dimension
and
what the importance of the
the intervention of neymar in your
decision
was it important to discuss with him
of course i've got some friends here
in the dressing room
when you
see the squad you really
want to play with them because there are
so many possibilities
to get what you want
we've got the same goals
when we were not together we had the
same goal and now that we are together
with neymar and the rest of the team
i hope we can make it
di maria paredes all these players i
know all the
teammates in the dressing room actually
and we had contact and
and neymar i of course did a lot
and and was important in my election
for a rap
you could play in champions league
against the french
squads but what do you know about french
football do you know the clubs it will
be a new
experience for you do you know some of
the teams do you know the players and do
you know the
the internal rivalries be between clubs
in france
yes of course
of course i've been following this and
i've got friends so i know
because of my friends in paris i was
following their games
and i think it's
this championship has been growing a lot
and paris has worked a lot for the
ligand growing up
because of the transfers
and so on
and i think the league is more
competitive and the
all the teams are getting stronger
because they want to win against paris
and want to win the league arm
so it's it will be a new experience for
me
i will have a new
new rivals and
new stages and i'm very happy to
experience
all this new
atmosphere
congratulations leo
on your
signing i'm happy to see you smile today
because it was different in barcelona a
few days ago what would you say to the
inches the fans in barcelona because
they are really sad because of your exit
they don't want
barcelona to play against you in
champions
would you like to avoid as well such a
game
and what would you say to the fans that
are very sad today
of course it was very complicated to
exit barcelona without knowing where i
was going to go
and barcelona is my home i've been there
since i was a kid
i've been i've lived so many things
there good things and bad things they
knew
i was going to
arrive in a very very strong team and
a team who was
aiming to win the champions league i
love
to win
i want to
have important goals
i know that my goals and paris goals are
the same
and we want to be bigger and bigger
i don't know if we're going to play and
to face each other barcelona and paris
it would be very nice to go back to
barcelona
i hope it would be with the fans when
it's possible because of the pandemic
it would be very strange to
play in
at home
there in barcelona with another shot but
it can happen and we'll see
good morning leah
good morning president
eh
people always think that you
you would never go out of your comfort
zone so
but today we you're here
you remember this little boy in new
worlds in argentina
what was your dream then
when
president did you know that all of this
could be possible when did you realize
with leonardo that you could have messi
here in paris
of course there are so many things
changing since i was in
new worlds and then in barcelona so many
things
arrived in my life so many good and bad
experiences
as a player and as a person
what i can say today
is i've got the same will and the same
same
enthusiasm than when i was a kid i still
feel like this kid i i'm
i'm gonna give my best
to achieve these goals
between both sides
to uh
to make this happen and it was true it
was very quick when liu decided to
to leave barcelona or you know to finish
with barcelona i mean you know
the discussion started and it was the
desire both side that we want to sign
and we are here
uh hello laura scott from the bbc
um
for the president
uh there's a lot of people wondering how
you can afford to have um such an
amazing squad and stick within ffp can
you tell us please and to to leo uh i
wonder how influential that phone call
was that you had with pochettino and and
how much he convinced you to come here
and what was said
regarding the financial will be i'll
just make it very clear thank you very
much for recording actually you know
i was waiting for it and uh
it's very great uh question for us
always as we said you know we followed
the financial fair player regulation
from the day one that we started until
the end we can have always fulfilled the
regulation of the financial aid play
before we do any things basically you
know we look out with our commercial
people with financial people with legal
people so as soon as if you see that
we're signing leo that's mean we could
we have the capacity to sign him if not
we're not gonna sign him we're not gonna
promise something we couldn't so we know
that we could sign him and i think uh
today as you can see i mean
what leopold was bringing to the club
it's a huge and that's i think what you
as media need also to focus in it's not
just the only the negative side let's
say but i think there's a lot of
positive he's bringing to the club and
you can see in everything in the term of
commercial
of social media that's amazing honestly
it is i mean you know a big asset for
the club the club being increased in
every single
part of the club in term of commercial i
mean unbelievable three days i mean you
know later we'll maybe give you some
numbers you're gonna be shocked honestly
in the
numbers that we have i hope leo will not
ask for more salary but
you know it's like but i think no we
have really i mean fantastic we
through that always we look at financial
replay and always
will uh will fulfill the the financial
player regulation thank you
as i said before
the whole dressing room and
the technical
staff
had an influence of on my decision
when we saw it was possible the first
thing we did was
talking to them and to pochettino
because we've been knowing each other
for a long time
and because we are both argentinian it's
easier of course
because we are close
in a way
of course we talk
we talked and
it's been very easy since the very
beginning
and i already said that but i'm going to
repeat and
all the squad and the staff
made a lot to help me choose this club
a question for the presidents here
good morning and congratulations welcome
leah
this
work
after so many years
you will all
receive
uh
the good things
uh you in psg but also the other teams
how do you picture the goods the
positive aspects for the league of this
transfer
today we are talking about psg but but i
i always work with all the
the teams
and i think we work with the
championship and the championship is
going to grow because of this and i hope
the broadcasting rights
will
will be higher because of that i'm
thinking about all the
all the parts
because i think now everybody wants to
see
psg games so
it's going to be positive for all the
rest of the clubs
i really want to thank
the presidents
who
sent me messages or called me
because they wanted to
talk about the
the arrival of lia
i think
i think that everybody knows that we're
not only working for our club but also
for france and for the league
i really want to thank vanson librine as
well
because all the clubs and especially
paris
we receive help from them and
we feel very lucky today because we're
here to work and to grow
the work is going to begin today for us
for the other clubs and for the league
and for the city as well for paris
i think what we are doing
for the club
is not only for the club but also for
the city
we all can
benefit from this situation two last
questions
good morning presidents
welcome leo to paris
you say a few days ago leo that you
really pictured the end of the career of
your career in barcelona
but i i'm sure the challenge doesn't
scare you now so maybe the biggest
challenge after almost 20 years in
barcelona
is a challenge
about your life
the change of country the new language
for you and your family
is it your biggest challenge
yes that's true the only thing i told
leonardo
was i really hoped my family would be
at ease in paris and would feel okay
here in paris in france
of course for me it's a new experience
but i'm really
i'm really ready for that
i really want
to do it
at the end of the day it's football and
football is the same in in the whole
world
i've got friends here and that's
something that that's going to make
things
easier
i'm sure i'm going to get used to my new
teammates and i'm really really happy
i really want to begin now and and to
begin to train and
know my teammates and have contacts with
them with all of them
i really want to train
i want it to begin now
this is new for us but i'm ready
in the sporting access aspect and for my
family it's an amazing city it's
beautiful and i i'm sure we are going to
enjoy
this place so we are quiet and happy
a question for
leonardo carter
four years ago verratti could have come
to
barcelona
and today four years after that
you meet him here
in
could it be what
chevy
of course verati
is showing the best play
and is showing how big a player is he is
of course in barcelona they really
wanted to have
him and and today it's the reverse
situation i'm coming to psg so
he is an incredible person and is an
incredible player a phenomenon is
spectacular
but not only marco verratti the
entire dressing room
these are the best players in the world
at all the positions
it's a
great squad and i hope i can help and
bring
my paws
to
achieve the goals
the goals of psg and my personal goals
thank you very much thank you everybody
[Applause]
sorry we couldn't take all the questions
sorry
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
hey mommy
you